this is the kokuma refugee camp in
northwestern kenya hundreds of thousands
of people live here but only one percent
of the population has access to
electricity from the main grid
instead most people rely on diesel power
generators that are expensive and
unreliable
vasco hamisi is changing that he's a
refugee from the democratic republic of
congo he knows how hard life can be
without access to affordable electricity
i decided to go in a green energy first
when i came here we are really
struggling
to get light
hemisi set up his company in 2017 and
secured funding from donors to build a
solar-powered mini grid
ocapi green energy now supplies
electricity to more than 200 businesses
including this shop run by another
refugee from the drc
with a reliable electricity supply i've
been able to buy a refrigerator i sell
cold drinks water and fresh mango juice
we're very grateful because this power
really helps us businesses pay hermesi's
company around seven dollars a month
that's about half the amount other
operators charge but demand is
outstripping supply i've seen that we
are still having more potential people
who are still coming to ask for
connection but for the power that we
have the 20 kilowatts that we have we
cannot connect everyone in kakuma plans
are underway to replicate the
solar-powered project in other parts of
the camp to build a brighter future for
the people living there
victoria gatenbee al jazeera